make you play half-court good screen by
Zaza hey you're gonna wipe out a guy on
the heat do it nicely and Pachulia that
was a full seal pigeon he can put up
points in a hurry
Steph a little freedom and then drop it
into three right in front of Derek Jeter
playing good team basketball it really
is
Steph Curry taking the foul and flipping
it up and in
Steph it's made a little bit of an
adjustment against the heat or in their
losses
the corner
we've seen that play in recent games of
their normal average which is 18th in
the league you would think I don't make
the words by him taking quick shots
please answer right back with Steph
character a pond I was a beautiful
screen doesn't have that quite yet my
mom would know play Ellington for the
three exclusively he can feast on Olynyk
at the center spot with Nick Young
denied Slater's on food inside moves
[Applause]
dropping in the deep to watch Kevin on
this play
hurry on the baseline it's interesting
right in front of Draghi cheese speed
looked waved and said you know you go
ahead thing the Warriors have going for
him now as a dion Waiters just wanna be
deep rely on him for 20 is game and
curry hits another three saw that lob
the whole way he was ready passed step
flipping it up in hand you don't usually
see klay Thompson make that kind of play
in the open court that Steph Curry loves
it defenders Rogich 10 and of 13 from
the field I love this play default is
looking around just got it off to beat
the shot clock buzzer the ultimate
patience by curry
lobbie to a backwards curry cook his fan
of the ball he's got clay over there he
knows it
and Durant wonderful yeah that's the 20
nice great hero 90 industry what's he
got here the magical moves your new sub
was coming under the backboard which
ways he could it go
and the jump and the reverse he like
that and the Warriors have their biggest
lead of the name threes but as a very
clever spin off glass